what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime operor and in this video i will be
breaking down
what is in my opinion one of the best
moments
in anime and manga i'm of course talking
about the intense
dramatic and heartbreaking reunion
between aaron and reiner
after the four year time skip in attack
on titan
this moment showcases why attack on
titan is such an amazing story and it
really drives home the incredible
character development
that both aaron and reiner have gone
through over the course of the series
despite featuring giant fantastical
monsters
the attack on titan story remains one of
the most raw and realistic depictions of
the true nature of
war the aaron and reiner reunion is a
prime example of that
so let's get into it if you enjoy our
attack on titan content
and you want to see more do me a favor
and click that like button
and if you're new to anime out pro or
you just haven't subscribed make this
the video that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you really have to go through the
trouble of clicking that bell and then
selecting the option that says
all i know it's annoying it's an extra
step but if you don't do that you're
still gonna miss a ton of our videos
even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works finally
don't forget to check out our growing
attack on titan playlist i will link the
playlist
down in the description and in the
pinned comment
now we all know what happened on
parodies island after the fall of wall
maria
and we know how these events set the
entire story of attack on titan
into motion at least from our own
perspective as the viewers
the fall of walmaria led to grisha
passing the founding and attack titan
powers onto aaron
and it also led to aaron developing an
obsession with revenge that would
eventually drive him to join the survey
corps
the fall of walmaria and the events that
followed also led reiner to develop
massive psychological and emotional
problems which continued to haunt him
throughout the entire attack on titan's
story
when reiner first came to the island of
paradise he firmly believed that
everyone on the island was an evil
devil and he was convinced that he had
to destroy these devils
in order to save his own people in
liberio and to save the entire world
in fact reiner was so convinced that
what he was doing was right that he
pressured annie and bertolt to continue
on with the mission
even after they considered aborting it
altogether following the death of marcel
but reiner was determined to see the
mission through
to the end he was determined to be a
hero who saves his loved ones from the
impending threat
posed by the so-called island devils
and so while maria was breached the
titans
entered shiganshina and thousands of
innocent people died
including of course aaron's own mother
but even though reiner came to paradise
believing that he was fighting these
irredeemably evil devils the years that
he spent on the island as an
infiltrator drastically changed his
opinion about the islanders
this is best showcased when reiner
returns to liberio after the time skip
and his family asks him about how he
managed to live with the island devils
for so long
officially reiner pays lip service to
marland propaganda about paradise by
saying that everyone on the island was
indeed
a barbarous devil he has to say this of
course
because saying anything else would get
him in big trouble in marley
however when reiner goes on to list off
examples of why the people of parodies
were such
barbarous devils he ends up listing
ordinary
quirky and completely harmless things
like sasha's love for potatoes
kony's goofiness jean's irresponsibility
and so on
when he does this reiner is actually
humanizing the aliens on parodies to his
family
he is saying that there are all kinds of
people there
people with their own unique quirks and
personalities people who are not that
different from the people in liberio
and everywhere else he can't say it
directly he has to preface it by stating
that yeah of course they're all devils
but the message is clear for everyone
who is paying attention
reiner knows that he was lied to he
knows that marleigh's propaganda was
false at the end of the day the aldians
on the island
are just normal people some are good
some are bad
and others are somewhere in between now
that he knows
this truth reiner is tortured by
feelings of guilt for what he had done
on the island and how much suffering his
actions brought to
thousands of normal innocent people this
is the state of mind that reiner is in
when he finally comes face to face with
aaron
once again as we know aaron had
pretended to be a wounded soldier
in order to infiltrate liberio just in
time for the big festival
and the big declaration of war against
parodies
but before he puts his plans into motion
aaron wanted to have a face to face with
reiner
at the same time that aaron and reiner
are meeting after four long years
willie tiber is delivering his big
speech about how the islanders are
dangerous and how they pose an
existential threat
to the entire world willie says that
because aaron possesses the founding
titan power he could initiate the
rumbling and use it to destroy the
entire world
as long as he can find some sort of link
to the royal bloodline
the point of willy's speech is that
aaron jaeger
the current holder of the founding titan
is a massive threat
to the entire world and that the world
must come together and declare war on
parodies
and eliminate this threat once and for
all
aaron tells reiner that willie is right
aaron
is the bad guy now at least from the
perspective of the people in liberio
and aaron might just end up destroying
the world someday
if he can find a way to harness the
founding titan's power
but aaron also reminds reiner that to
him they looked like the bad guys back
when they breached while maria
destroyed aaron's hometown and enabled
the smiling titan to eat aaron's mom
right before his eyes aaron asks reiner
why why did so many innocent people in
paradise have to suffer
and die why did all of this have to
happen
reiner admits that it was all because of
the warriors
their mission was to infiltrate the
walls and see how the king inside the
walls would react
if the king didn't react and the
pacifism rumors turned out to be true
then the ultimate objective of the
warriors was to retake the founding
titan
in order to save the world from the evil
island devils
or at least that is what they were
taught to believe through marlene
propaganda
aaron says that he finally understands
what reiner had gone through
initially aaron saw everyone on the
other side of the sea
as an enemy just as reiner saw everyone
on the island as an enemy
it's easy to hate and want to destroy
people you've never even met
or had a chance to relate to in any
meaningful way
i mean just look at twitter it's perfect
proof of exactly that
but after aaron infiltrated marley he
realized that while there are some
terrible people here
there are also good people there are
people here who are generous and kind
and completely innocent
people who had nothing to do with what
happened on parodies
the truth is that both across the sea
and within the walls people are all the
same there are good people
there are bad people and there are
people who are somewhere in between
aaron now knows that reiner also
suffered
even as he willingly perpetrated untold
horrors back on parodies
after all reiner was just an ignorant
child who was brainwashed by ignorant
adults and made to think that he was
saving the world by destroying the
so-called
island devils reiner was shaped by his
environment and by his history
and that is why he went through with the
mission to attack paradise
reiner truly believed that this is what
he had to do in order to save his
own people aaron understands reiner now
because aaron
is in a very similar position marlee and
the other nations are about to declare
war on paradise
they are about to attack the island
again and that means that they are going
to try and kill
everyone that aaron ever loved and cared
about
even though there are definitely good
people and innocent people here in
liberio and
all over marley the people in charge are
about to destroy aaron's loved ones
unless he stops them this is the same
predicament that reiner thought that he
was in
back when he attacked paradise it may
not have been true
but that is what he believed and that is
what drove him to keep moving forward
with his mission
but to reiner's credit he doesn't just
blame all his actions
on his environment he says that yes his
environment did play a part
but he also takes personal
responsibility for his decision to
attack
parodies he admits that beyond just the
marlin propaganda
he genuinely wanted to be a hero and he
wanted to be a respected warrior
that is why he convinced annie and
bertolt to continue on with the mission
even after they wanted to give up and
head back to marley
reiner now feels an incredible amount of
guilt about what he did on paradise
and he feels that guilt personally he
doesn't just blame marley he doesn't
just blame brainwashing he blames
himself for choosing to go along with
all of it just so he could be accepted
and respected by marlene society
reiner is so overcome by guilt that he
actually asks aaron to just kill him
and put him out of his misery reiner can
no longer
live with his guilt and even though
reiner knows that aaron is probably
about to go ham on liberio and you would
think that reiner's first instinct would
be to protect liberio
reiner is so broken that he doesn't even
have the will to fight
aaron he simply gives up because he
feels that death at the hands of aaron
is exactly what he deserves for his
actions on parodies
but aaron doesn't kill reiner
instead he holds his hand out to reiner
and the two of them class
pants aaron could have killed reiner at
this moment
and if he did it would have made the
rest of his mission easier
the armored titan would have been taken
out of the equation and this would have
increased the likelihood that aaron's
plan would ultimately succeed
but aaron doesn't kill reiner because he
feels for him
and he understands him the two of them
are two sides of the same
coin both of them were destined to do
terrible things
in order to protect the ones they love
and just as reiner kept moving forward
with his mission back on parodies
aaron vows to keep moving forward as
well until all of his enemies
are destroyed in the very next moment
aaron transforms into his titan form and
unleashes his destructive power
on the people of liberio this includes
the tibers
the marlayan military leaders other
global leaders and unfortunately
it includes civilians as well just as
reiner believed that he was doing the
right thing when his actions destroyed
thousands of innocent lives and parodies
aaron believes that he
is doing the right thing now the right
thing for his own people
and his own loved ones what a powerful
moment
this is both in terms of drama and in
terms of the personal character
development for both
aaron and reiner this is exactly what
war
is and this is what it does there are no
winners in war
everyone suffers and usually there are
no clear-cut
good guys and bad guys either everyone
thinks that they are the good guys
and they all think that their enemies
must be the bad guys
but there are usually good people and
bad people on all sides
and innocent civilians always suffer on
all sides of every conflict
reiner thought that he was doing the
right thing to protect his people
and so he attacked parodies aaron and
many others were traumatized by what
reiner and the warriors had done
and now they think that they are doing
the right thing and protecting their own
people by attacking liberio
but the people of liberia are now going
to be traumatized by aaron's attack and
they will grow to hate him
and see him as a villain they will then
want to seek revenge against him because
from their perspective he is the bad guy
who attacked their homes
and the cycle of hatred and violence
will continue and
sadly this is exactly what happens in
our own world
some countries in our world have been
going back and forth and fighting each
other for literally hundreds of years
because of this vicious cycle of hatred
and violence
and of course every country tends to see
itself as good and just
and its enemies as evil and unjust
and that is why this is such an amazing
moment
not only does it offer incredible drama
and intensity
and not only does it give us a glimpse
into some of the best character
development in modern anime
but it also teaches a very powerful
lesson about the true nature
and true cost of war this lesson
applies just as much to our own world as
it does to the world of attack on titan
and this is a lesson that we must never
forget
no one wins in war everyone loses in the
end
everyone suffers and war is almost never
a matter of evil bad guys getting what's
coming to them and then shows over let's
go home
rather it's always the innocent
civilians on all sides who suffer the
most
and with every violent act the cycle of
violence continues
those who are victimized want to strike
back and get their revenge
but once they do their enemies will want
to do the same to them
and the cycle keeps moving forward
thank you guys so much for watching this
video and please let me know what you
guys thought about the aaron and reiner
reunion moment
did you think that it was as important
and as powerful
as i did and is this one of your
favorite moments
in anime do you have some other favorite
moments from attack on titan or even
some other anime that you like even more
than this moment
definitely drop me a line down in the
comments below and make your voices
heard
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more attack on titan content
right here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you're new to
anime pro
or maybe just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video do you subscribe and
hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram
at animeapror a big thank you to all of
our anime outpour patrons for making
videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma a
disciple of
lord twigo himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect pate hepha
rathee and yx
emperor otaku spidey life canal big
buddhist and tungsten tarkis
finally thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
joe stanton barry gucci jessica
kaylafond rathune deora alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokamian water the
red-haired raymond florian
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games
deadly saint matthew cruz anthony
schreiber hi jinx and mr waffles 247.
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you